who's your pick Ron DeSantis or Trump
Hey listen whoever whoever wins the
primary it's whom I pick is yeah but
okay so if you have to vote on primary
who you choosing
that's not the question though let me
explain to you that's not the question
you know why because Trump right now has
got a 40-point lead on him according to
CPAC wow okay but who's your pick I I
think I think both of them are Fighters
both Trump and the scientists are
Fighters my only concern is the
following there's a part of me that
wants the guy to get up and finish a
second term yeah okay I see that so so
for me I like 12 years instead of eight
years so what do I mean by 12 years
if the sentence goes eight years it's
probably gonna be somebody else on the
flip side sure but if Trump goes four
years for sure it's the Santa's next
right after yeah so you you can choose 8
or 12 I prefer 12. yeah I prefer 12.
because I think this to do what we want
to do you need more than four years yes
if you get you know when's the last time
we had 12 consecutive years of the
simple same political party you know
what it was Reagan Bush yeah Reagan
bushes it was from 80 to 92 12 years and
Reagan was his VP right so here it could
be four and eight years yeah we go on a
12-year run
we're in good shape we're in good shape
yeah good times ahead yes if if you were
to if you were to list
the top five issues in the US right now
one being the most pressing in your
opinion
what would they be
so top five hero making machine is
number one we've been confused with
who's a hero okay okay you know what did
Biden say the transgender is the the
fabric of what America was found some
words what are you talking about right
again that's a confusion of who the hero
is whatever the president edifies that's
what the populace is going to want to be
whatever the parent edifies the other
day video is going viral on Tick Tock
and the son says my mom as long as I say
I'm gay that's what makes my mom happy
my mom just wants me to be part of it
yeah yeah they went live and say what
I've never said that yeah Mom your dream
is for me to be gay right yeah so if the
mom edifies gay being the hero that's
what the kid's gonna do yeah so so if
president edifies job creators
readers
entrepreneurs those who protect the
country Patriots if the if the president
edifies the right hero during that time
those Heroes rise up yes if we edify the
wrong Heroes the wrong Heroes rise up so
to me number one problem we have is a
hero making machine okay we're turning
the wrong people into Heroes and people
are confused what is a hero yeah is
should I be part of the Rich and you
know famous you know is it bad to be
rich today is it bad to create well
today is it bad they're so confused
right now
we have to protect the borders there's
no question about it with the way China
is coming in through you know Mexico and
the fentanyl issue that we're having too
many kids going through drugs and The
Nightlife scene right now nightlife
scene right now is very weird with the
kind of drugs that people are using we
got to protect that part uh
military-wise I think we have to the the
the the battle is going to win on who's
going to master and play the best
defense in cyber bio I mean that's the
direction China is going so where are
our resources going you know naval ships
you know they're realizing through naval
ships the Investments they're making
very very strategic the partnership I
would look at the mistake we made with
China and I know we're gradually moving
our manufacturing over to India I would
make sure the way that Nixon set up to
deal with China the way you set up the
deal with India because we are going to
go to India but we cannot think just
because we get along with Modi today
that the way we set up with India we're
always going to get along with Modi the
next
and India could be China 2.0 in 20 years
so I would set up the negotiation with
India in a different way than they did
with China and I would diversify a
little bit of manufacturing but we're
not relying 80 percent in one place
we can't do that we we you want us
you want to you want to be proud like
you know people go work at a company and
they say it on their resume I worked at
Amazon I worked at Microsoft I worked at
Google that's a bragging right I worked
at Goldman Sachs my resume people brag
about where they worked at right okay
great hey we we do business with America
we do business it's always been with
America right right now it's China so
I would also figure out a way to go have
the kneecap to kneecap meetings with all
these powerful people and uh you know
figure out a way to kind of we're
strengthening the enemies too much yeah
everybody United with each other China
Russia Iran Saudi now they're all part
of the same team yeah those are not four
people you want that part of the same
team so we got some work to do with
foreign relations as well but those will
be I think you mentioned it too when
you're when your competitor likes the
president that you have that's a red
flag
yeah just crazy of course like if people
are happy buttons and powder Power
foreign
[Music]